Free Palestine.
>> What' you say?
>> When Free Palestine was said, I stayed
silent out of the fear of losing
sponsors. He's talking about when XQC
said free Palestine and then stared at
Mr. Beast.
Do not forget to check out Cindi.com.
Brothers and sisters, one of my most
amazing clothing brands that I wear,
alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims. With
the recent boycott that's going on with
many brands, clothing lines supporting
Israel. Brothers and sisters, you guys
know I've been supporting si.com. I've
been wearing their stuff long, long time
ago. Alhamdulillah. And I love their
clothing, brothers and sisters. It's
exactly what I like. Alhamdulillah. When
it comes to fitness, training, jogging,
just general wear when I'm praying. I
don't need to worry about my back
showing. Buy it for your family members,
your your uncles, your brothers, your
husbands, whoever it is. Inshallah, bro,
sisters. Buy it for yourself. Inshallah.
It's modest. Welcome to brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well, inshallah. So, this was a
video that I came across on Tik Tok of
Mr.
and um to say the least I was um I
wouldn't be I wouldn't say I was
surprised um you know to to an extent
but seeing his reaction and this is a
live you can't make this stuff up you
know pre-recorded stuff here I can make
a mistake here do it again etc not with
a live with a live you see genuine
reaction here's the footage is off we're
going to watch inshallah with I think
his name is Eden Ross Rosen I don't know
his names I'll be honest with you and
the other guy I don't know who he is as
well look at their reaction yeah their
reaction obviously he's himself a Jewish
Ed Edin, I think his name is Edin or
something. Um, even he says free
Palestine, but look at the reaction of
Mr. Beast. And then afterwards,
apparently there's an apology that he
came out with. We don't know if it's
real or not. We're going to find out
inshallah. Let's watch this for
ourselves. Inshallah. And I want you
guys because this shows me Mr. Beast,
all of his humanitarian work that he did
in Africa, curing the blind, all that
kind of is just fake. All of that is
fake. You know why? Because if you
cannot if you are so uncomfortable
talking or helping or aiding the people
in Gaza. Yes. That means all of
humanitarian aid is is fake. You're a
fake person. That's what you are. Let's
watch oursel.
>> Okay.
>> Shortahholic xQCL
300 for the 500.
>> Oh, Train said we got to read all 300
first. Oh [__] Is that what Train just
told you?
>> Oh, wait. Let's go back. Backwood
Chamra.
>> Question. Somebody in my chat was
wondering uh who what's your name?
>> Cena.
>> Oh sabaza.
>> Wait uh what's your background?
>> I'm Turkish.
>> Turkish.
>> An anonymous dor.
>> No we like you and drink. Okay.
>> I need to scream at you.
>> Free Palestine.
>> What' you say?
>> No.
>> Dr. McNugget.
>> So that's the first reaction. Let's go a
bit closer. Here's the second one. Free
Palestine.
>> What' you say?
>> Yo.
>> Oh boy.
>> So funny. Felix,
>> might as well just keep reading it,
dude.
>> Adso. Lindel.
>> Lindlau.
>> Linda. Lindlau.
>> Free Palestine.
[Music]
>> Safar.
>> You can see both of the guys in the back
are doing it on purpose. They're saying
they're looking at his reaction because
those guys are they they support the
courts. So they're looking at his
reaction and you can see I've never seen
anyone so damn careless. Imagine living
in Nazi Germany or you know when in
Congo when 10 million Congolese were
mass you know killed by King Leopard II.
Yes. And imagine the reaction is just oh
casual on my phone. No damn care about
human life. If someone said to me, "One
person died, a child died." You won't
see me on the phone like, you know,
scrolling on my phone like just like,
you know, like nothing happened. He
knows there's a genocide happening. A
massacre, mass massacre. He's just
casually on his phone. No two crabs
given. It's the reality. This is the
people you Muslims look up to.
>> Free Palestine.
>> Are you starting to lose your mind?
>> Give me one sec. I'll be right back.
>> So here, this one, I don't know. There
might be a cut paste. make it look like
he was he left etc as far as I know. So
from what I can see brother and sisters
is that from the actual footage of
actually what happened because these
some of them can be cut and paste is is
is there was even like a smirk. Now the
thing is what we need to understand like
Allah says in the Quran you know he
gives a parable of the person who has
multiple masters compared to the one who
has one master. You can see Mr. Beast's
masters are many. It's definitely not
truth because you can see very clearly
he's uncomfortable. Now, if that is the
case, like we can watch some other
videos here where you've got Aisha
Speed. Let's watch Aisha Speed for
example. Look at his reaction. He's
someone who's very very popular. Look at
Look at his reaction.
>> You're from Palestine. What's up, my
Palestinians?
>> Free Palestine.
Freedom boys in the chat.
>> What? Free Palestine. What's funny?
>> I don't know. I don't know what's funny.
>> [__] Don't be laughing.
>> Can I say it too?
>> Palestine.
>> Free Palestine. Bro,
>> it's not a joke.
>> It's not.
>> No.
>> This is a video from Sneo. So, this
video from Sne. Let's watch. Let's see
what he had to I've done Project of Tar.
If you guys want to, I'll do it again.
But I'm seeing these massive people.
It's like, if we're going to really if
we're going to give out water and food
to people that really need it, uh,
they're destroying crates as soon as
they land. People are starving to death.
There's like endless images of children
stuff for law. They're they're
shriveling up. They have no They're
starving. Let's do something about that,
huh? Let's use our influence for that.
Doesn't have to be controversial.
>> So, you can see that Mr. Beast is is
fake. Why is he fake? Because at the end
of the day, you can clearly see that if
he genuinely cared about people,
if this when he went to feed the people
in Africa, when he did the eye surgeries
in a different country, all this
humanitarian stuff, it's PR. It's never
genuine because if it was, just put it
this if his issue is the Gaza,
Palestine, I might lose deals or this,
etc. If that's the case, or if it's
controversial, he's fearing backlash for
whatever reason it is, he's going to get
more backlash, whatever it is. Yeah.
he's fearing his income or sponsorships
or whatever. They've categorically told
him don't get involved. That means if
those African children were
Palestinians, he would have not helped
them. If those eye surgeries were
pertaining to Palestinian children, he
would have not helped them. When
Palestine is put on those humanitarian
aids that he's done, he would have not
helped because the moment Palestine is
mentioned free Palestine, he could have
come and react and say, you know what,
I'm actually very sorry for what's going
on there. It's heartbreaking. I wish I
can do something to help. Sufficient
emotions. It's genuine which shows that
all of those humanitarian stuff that he
said it's all rubbish because it shows I
will do a why because what am I going to
get back in return when the moment it
comes to Gaza and palace and he's like
yo I can lose brand deals and I've been
told clearly by my managers if I do this
because he's thinking about his business
which shows that he's a slave he is a
slave to all of those masters those
people behind him saying to him do not
dare get involved in politics do not
dare say that or for example if We do
that you know we are funded by a big
Zionist billionaire. Okay so you cannot
say it which shows what you my friend
are a slave like Allah says in the Quran
and true true freedom is what? Enslaving
yourself to the creator because that
means in Islam justice if I heard a the
killing of let me tell you something
Zionist child if I heard anyone a pro
Palestinian saying yes we should go and
massacre a Zionist child I'll say you
are out of your mind. What the hell are
you talking about? They're not our
teachers. But you can see clearly with
Mr. Beast. Yeah. He's moving like a
beast. Yes. What is a beast is a a
beast? Look, you need to understand a
beast, an animal does what it needs to,
his instincts. Yes. That's what he
moves. You can see, let me tell you
something. If a animal, if an animal
understood our language, if an animal, I
believe, an animal may have had a
different reaction. Sometimes you see
lions who catch a baby deer and they
just pat it. They don't harm it. Like
you can see there's even this instant.
You can't blame the live for eating it,
but doesn't even do that. It sometimes
just pets it and knows that it's
innocent and knows that it's vulnerable
and knows that he can't do anything.
You've got someone who's Mr. Beast. You
are a beast. I'm going to call you are a
beast. Not in that good sense, in a
negative sense. Yes. Because you showed
no emotions. You did not even react.
Yes. And here's a clip of apparently his
apology which is absolutely we found out
is fake. Here's apparently what he said.
I don't even know why this guy made this
up.
>> Mr. finally says free Palestine and he's
going to help the people in Gaza. Check
it out. I owe you all an apology. During
my recent charity stream, when free
Palestine was said, I stayed silent out
of the fear of losing sponsors. He's
talking about when XQC said free
Palestine and then stared at Mr. Beast.
XQC knew Mr. Beast wasn't going to say
anything. But check this out. That
silence was strong. Helping people
should never come with conditions.
Facts. and human lives are more
important than any brand deal. I want to
be clear, I do stand with Palestine.
Innocent people are suffering and they
deserve the same compassion and support
I've shown through other causes. Moving
forward, I will be using my platform not
only to raise money for charity, but
also to highlight organizations
providing direct aid to in Gaza and
Palestine. I messed up by not speaking
when it mattered most. I won't make that
mistake again. Wow, Mr.
actually saved his entire career.
Everybody thought he was just like, you
know, just the guy who wouldn't say
anything about this, but he's actually
helping now. What do y'all think?
>> Well, we think that's a big fat lie.
It's bull crap. He never said that. We
haven't seen anything. If he's tweeted
it, he's deleted it. And there's no way
he's going to say that. There is no way
he's going to say that. And let me tell
you something, guys. If he does come out
and say something, it's because he is
afraid to lose business again, which is
you guys. So, Subhan Allah. What I'm
going to say is I mean if you're going
to carry on watching this shameless man
who showed not an atom way of emotion to
millions thousands of people who've been
massacred starving and he's the one who
wants to go and help other people you
can see it is nothing but fake so that's
all I wanted to say brother sister
inshallah and shed his far and wide in
Muslims boycott this man this man should
be ashamed of himself he cares about
nothing but money that's his slave
that's his god that's what he worships
he doesn't care about human life it
depends what kind of benefits he takes
out of it and that's what his intentions
are. So that's the reason why when we
look at these people, we think, "Oh
yeah, they're helpful." They're not,
man. They're not genuinely deep down
they're not. Why? Because he makes
money. Giving out cars and this that
he's doing it for the views cuz that
channels him to do more stuff. So you
can see how fake it is. The intentions.
That's why in Islam, intentions are very
important. Every action is based on an
intention. Mr. Beast, shame on you and
Palestine will be free. Inshallah. It is
the end, the beginning of the end of
Israel. And I hope we live to see
because the whole entire world hate
them.